general ade ihres vaters und
zugeschaltet ehemaliger brigadegeneral
der bundeswehr und militär politischer
berater im bundeskanzleramt guten abend
herr
frost versuchen gemeinsam so etwas zu
verstehen wie sich die militärische
situation dort jetzt entwickelt gerade
auch mit blick erstmal auf diesen wert
auch für laien sehr eindrücklichen
konvoi in die russen der richtung kiel
schicken der 60 kilometer oder noch
länger sein soll was für schlüsse ziehen
sie aus solchen bildern und
informationen von von so einem konvoi
naja die kräfte die jetzt im raum sind
waren die kräfte der ersten staffel die
russen gehen jetzt mit den haupt kräften
der zweiten staffel weiter vor das ist
eindrucksvoll auf den bildern zu sehen
und es geht ihnen jetzt darum kiew zu
nehmen also zumindest so zu belagern
auszutrocknen dass da kein widerstand
mehr kommen kann aber sie müssen auch
mit spezialkräften rein weil in kiew ja
die politische leitung des landes ist
auch die militärische leitung es geht um
die führung letztlich des gesamten
ukrainischen widerstandes und die läuft
aus kiew deswegen ist von strategischer
bedeutung deswegen diese massive militär
konzentration gerade bei kiew es heißt
dass in diesem konvoi auch panzer zu
sehen sind und schweres
artilleriegeschütz was jetzt eigentlich
nicht für irgendwelche kleineren oder
präzisere schläge gedacht dass das
massiv zerstört also geht man mit sowas
in eine großstadt rein
ja ich glaube sie werden nicht wahllos
in die stadt schießen aber es ist
natürlich das problem bei den
sogenannten urban warfare also bei
kämpfen im urbanen umfeld
das zivilbevölkerung immer in
mitleidenschaft gezogen wird das kann
man fast gar nicht ausschließen der
verteidiger nutzt das natürlich auch die
zivile infrastruktur und kann sich da
auch sehr gut aufstellen und der
angreifer das sind jetzt die russen die
müssen halt sehen wie sie die stadt
freikämpfen um letztlich auch die die
leitzentralen des landes zu
neutralisieren das ist eine schwierige
sache man kommt schnell in die städte
reihen also man die amerikaner haben das
ja in bagdad gesehen aber danach dort zu
bleiben das nachhaltig zu besetzen ist
ein ganz schwieriger job
könnte man so ein konto wenn ich
eigentlich auch angreifen ich mein der
zieht sich da vor aller augen kilometer
lang durch die gegend frage ich mich als
laie ob man die nicht aus der luft
beschießen kann die ukraine haben ja
auch noch flugzeuge oder naja ich glaube
die sind weitgehend neutralisiert die
russen haben ja in den ersten tagen mit
ihren luftstreitkräften auch mit ihren
raketen die flugplätze zerstört und die
luftabwehr neutralisiert der ukraine da
ist nicht mehr viel was die ukraine da
entgegensetzen können denn dann könnten
sie in der tat diese kolonnen angreifen
aber die russen haben augenscheinlich
die luft herrschaft ich denke davon muss
man ausgehen
deswegen haben sie da letztlich nicht zu
befürchten
was können denn die ukraine jetzt
überhaupt noch was kann die armee jetzt
überhaupt noch tun und kiew zu halten
oder ist das ja ich muss so rasch zu
glauben man könnte kiew halten ja das
ist frost raum ganz schwieriges thema
die kampfmoral der ukraine ist groß sie
es bewundernswert aber die russische
militärmaschine ist ja massiv überlegen
in allen haut waffensystemen und auch
der angriff im land man muss ja auch in
den süden gehen nicht also sie die
russen greifen aus der krise heraus
jetzt richtung usa an ich denke die
stadt wird auch in kürze genommen werden
und sie sind auf der anderen seite des
asowschen meeres eben auch im vormarsch
richtung dombach mario pohl waren die
kämpfe aber das ist jetzt auch mehr oder
weniger in russischer hand und die
landbrücke zwischen kremmen und das ist
auch geschlossen mehr oder weniger die
russen versuchen auch in der west
ukraine die den nachschub an waffen und
munition für die ukraine aus polen
heraus
letztlich abzuriegeln
inwieweit das erfolgreich ist muss man
sehen also die ukraine haben eigentlich
eher als rein militärisch betrachtet nur
die chance in einem die russen in einen
lang andauernden konflikt zu ziehen in
einen abnutzungskrieg und auf zeit zu
spielen
dazu müssen sie letztlich grill ja
taktisch vorgehen und das ist das was
putin weiß gott nicht will das ist seine
größte angst jetzt eigentlich in einen
langen abnutzungskrieg hineinzugeraten
mit in die ukraine an die ja für viele
russen auch ein bruder volk ist das ist
kann er sich nicht leisten das essen
rasanter aspekte wie so jemand man sieht
viel diese bilder die ukraine zivilisten
auch alte frauen männer quer beet sich
diesen soldaten diesen russen die sind
natürlich sprachlich alle die können
sich ja bestens verständigen die ukraine
und die russen in sich entgegenstellen
und sagen haut aus unserem land ab oder
anfang ukrainische lieder zu singen und
man hat zu den eindruck dass diese
russischen soldaten auch dahin gar nicht
wissen wie sie damit umgehen sollen ich
meine krieg ist auch psychologisch und
psyche war wie wirkt so etwas auf
soldaten wenn sie merken die sie in der
die bevölkerung so entgegen stellen eine
bevölkerung die ihnen eigentlich
kulturell sehr nahe
ja das ist mit sicherheit für viele
russische soldaten vor allen dingen die
die unmittelbar lässt sich an der front
sind ein problem das kann man sehr gut
nachvollziehen es gibt ja tausende von
verwandtschaftlichen beziehungen auch
zwischen ukrainer und russen es gibt ja
auch sehr viele ethnische russen in der
ukraine
deswegen kann sich putin einen lang
andauernden konflikt in der ukraine der
blutig ist der die zivilbevölkerung mit
einzieht kann er sich eigentlich nicht
leisten da ist jeder tag ein tag zu viel
für ihn der westen schaut bei all dem zu
also jedenfalls militärisch greift die
nato nicht ein
es gibt aber diese forderung nach
flugverbotszonen was würde beim prinzip
bedeuten die nato beginnt einen direkten
krieg mit russland eine atommacht
naja flugverbotszonen das haben wir ja
angewandt also im irak auch auf dem
balkan auch in libyen also das
funktioniert eigentlich nur mit einer
sehr stark militärisch überlegenen macht
gegenüber einem mehr oder weniger
militärischen habe nichts der so ein
bisschen luftstreitkräfte noch hat oder
hubschrauber da kann man sowas
etablieren wenn die nato das machen
würde dann wäre sie faktisch im krieg
mit russland die russen werden das
niemals zulassen
und das ist ein vorschlag der ein no go
ist letztlich für die nato und der
nato-generalsekretär ist ja gerade in
polen er hat auch die polen so ein
bisschen das polnische militär
zurückgepfiffen
auch diese idee der ukraine mit
kampfpiloten aus der polen
herauszuhelfen in dem konflikt da hat er
eindeutig ein riegel vorgeschoben weil
er partout nicht will und das ist
konsens auch in der nato dass die nato
als solches kriegspartei wird aber man
muss auch sehen durch unsere
waffenlieferungen sind wir faktisch
dabei in diese richtung und zu bewegen
nicht dass wir und wenn der krieg länger
dauern sollte der ukrainische widerstand
weitergeht dann kann das sehr schnell in
einen stellvertreterkrieg münden und
dann kann sich auch schnell die sache in
richtung auf eine kriegspartei
entwickeln das ist so ein risiko und das
kann man muss man politisch sehr sehr
gut steuern
damit man nicht in diese richtung
marschiert eine gefährliche situation
herr fertig danke für das gespräch
vielen dank fürs morgen war